hello and welcome
to bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
we hope that in this program uh in this
session you will learn
a little bit about bioinformatics and
how it's used to
study and characterize different types
of infectious diseases
and i hope that after this webinar you
will be
also you will be familiar with some of
the ways that bioinformatics is used
in covid19 research as well as the
design and development of novel
antiviral drugs and vaccines
we'll give you a little bit of a
perspective on how such
data is being used and how you yourself
can potentially use genomic data to
uh to apply to different types of
infectious pathogens
so after this webinar is over you're
also welcome to
explore our upcoming program
called bioinformatics for infectious
diseases it's a training program
that will allow you to be effective at
using
some of the types of tools that we'll be
discussing uh today
and uh hopefully you'll get a good sense
of what that will look like
so in this uh upcoming uh program uh
in a second i'm sorry
so today we'll talk about how the
emergence and development of
bioinformatics
in different types of tools for
infectious disease research
can be used to characterize
infection from different types of data
perspectives
and we'll also present several use cases
for bioinformatics analysis methods that
are used in pathogen diagnostics
viral evolutionary studies antiviral
drug discovery
vaccine design as well as the
characterization of for emerging drug
resistance
and to showcase uh some of these ideas
and some of these types of
uh projects we'll actually use uh the
t-biome for analytical platform then
we'll talk a little bit about
several sections specifically designed
for such studies that were
made available as a user-friendly
interface that you can also try
so we'll talk a little bit about what
the infectious diseases are
how can we characterize and study them
from a genomic perspective
what are some of the tools methods and
data sets that are available
and then we'll talk about this upcoming
program that will allow you to
learn how to use these tools effectively
i do want to mention that a lot of the
materials that we'll be discussing
today have been designed and developed
by
a team of researchers and a team of
bioinformaticians that work
at pine biotech but also at the
university of haifa in israel
in the tower excuse me at the tower
bioinformatics research center
so these include the lead scientists
that have
participated in research together with
other prominent labs
around the world and we will also
talk about some of the examples briefly
that have come out of those studies
a lot of the methods and tools as well
as the resources that we will discuss in
the context of the upcoming
bioinformatics for infectious disease
research
program will also be incorporated and
those have been designed
uh as uh by our team
of mentors including uh julia panov
mazumdar and harpreet khaor
and so even though i will be speaking i
will be presenting
different types of analyses and content
that will be presented in that program
and this was a
team effort for all of us so let's uh
start by talking a little bit about what
infection
is and so infectious disease
is the infection the result of infection
it's the invasion of an
organism's body tissues by
disease-causing agents
so it's their multiplication and the
reaction of the host tissues to the
infectious
agents and the toxins that they produce
so an
infection disease also known as a
transmissible disease or communicable
disease
is an illness resulting from an
infection
infections are caused by infectious
agents called pathogens and they include
viruses and related agents such as
periods
viroids bacteria fungi parasites
and those parasites could include
unicellular organisms like
malaria and macroparasites like worms
so non-infectious diseases as compared
to infectious diseases
are also recognized as chronic and can
be
caused by such factors as environment
nutrition
and lifestyle as well as genetic
inheritance
the world health organization recognizes
four main types of chronic and
non-infectious diseases
and those include cancer cardiovascular
diseases
chronic respiratory diseases like asthma
or chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
and diabetes now as you will see a lot
of these are actually not so
clearly separated a lot of them have
to do with each other for example
chronic diseases
might be a risk for infectious diseases
and infection can cause development of
chronic diseases
as we know about cancer autoimmune
diseases and many others
so in fact the separation between these
two types of diseases
is not very clear there's a lot of
overlap and there's also a lot of
different types of cause and effect uh
type of associations between these
different conditions
the replication of pathogens in the host
leads to major types of interference and
this starts from
membrane disruption as in the case with
viruses
and the release of toxins as in the case
of many bacterial pathogens
many of these interferences induce
molecular biological pathways designed
to fend off intruders
and signal to neighboring cells of the
upcoming danger
these pathogens can also modulate the
pathways
and cause long-term organ damage
such as lung tissue scarring due to the
immune hyperactivity
so in fact the same pathways that were
designed to prevent and stop this kind
of infection
can also lead to major types of effects
later on now uh
the hosts can fight infection using
their immune system so here
we have a few examples of how that
happens
mammalian hosts react to infection with
an
innate response often involving
inflammation followed by an adaptive
response
vaccines are used to train the immune
system and to identify
pathogens and store the necessary
epitopes for antibody production
in the long term immune memory but due
to a variety of factors such immune
responses can actually be insufficient
on their own
so two main approaches that have
significantly reduced
death from infectious diseases in the
past century
are antibiotics antiviral drugs
and vaccines vaccines have been
discovered first as far
back as the early 1800s and are becoming
major
have become major instruments to train
the human immune system in response to
various pathogens
reducing worldwide deaths significantly
in the 20th century
as a result of water treatment use of
vaccines and antibiotics
death rate from infectious diseases was
reduced
over tenfold in the 20th century
but the 21st century came around with
significant new challenges antibiotic
resistant bacteria
and the spread of such bacteria even in
places like hospitals
as well as significant new challenges
from novel
pandemic zoonotic viruses that we were
not prepared for
of course here you can see several
examples this is a brief timeline
of novel vaccine design and you can see
that
this type of an approach to vaccines
have has led
a lot of people to think that we are
done with infectious diseases in the
20th century and then the 21st century
came around
and of course such new challenges like
swine flu
bird flu ebola virus and covet 19
have really shown how unprepared we are
for these
viruses that are emerging and causing
pandemics over here you can see how
significantly the reduction of death
rate has been
as a result of different health
epidemiological measures
such as use of chlorine and water in the
united states
use of penicillin vaccines
etc has really reduced the death rate
and of course here you can see the
opposite picture what happened
in 2020 as here you can see the
comparison of
the rate of death from cobit 19 to 2017
death rates from other types of
conditions for example
drugs and alcohol diabetes
lung and tracheal bronchus cancers
and pulmonary disease so you can see
that covid19
is actually a higher uh the death rate
from carbon 19 has been
going up and we know that this is the
story is not over it continues
and so we'll see how bioinformatics
can help in some of these challenges
thankfully at the same time that the
pathogens were studied under the
microscope
humans also started developing
sequencing technologies that could help
decipher the human genome
and as a result such detailed enriched
molecular data has transformed our
understanding of infectious diseases and
pathogens themselves
in the last 20 years availability of
genomic data has lab
has led to an increasing understanding
of how cells function
at the molecular level and has allowed
us to understand major causes of deadly
diseases
with the current rise in viral outbreaks
and
their deadliness there's a major focus
on developing tools
and data repositories for a much better
understanding of the emergence
prevention
and treatment of infectious diseases as
a result
the major advances in data generation
analysis methods
and the utilization of insights from
such studies is making a completely new
approach to diagnostics
disease characterization and the
development of novel
interventions to such pathogens what you
can see here
is the way that sequencing is used to
study pathogens
we know that we can now assemble genomes
and accurately compare them between each
other
to understand how they are interrelated
and also develop
genetic markers so that we can
understand what are the drivers of
virulence and spread
and how they can be helpful in
diagnosing and detecting early
indications that there's resistance to
drugs and of course one of the major
uh capabilities of sequencing is that
this is digital data it's easy to store
manage and analyze
and so as a result there are many public
databases and data sets that allow us to
ask
very detailed and specific questions
about
some of these pathogens now as a result
of this capability of genomic sequences
we can now
understand and study population
structure and evolutionary
history we can also identify the
specific sequences
and very specifically identify the cause
of different types of
outbreaks we can have insights into
how to make such technology to identify
the specific strains
early on and hopefully take early on
measures for that
and then also we can use some of the
downstream analysis results to
inform drug design and vaccine design as
can be shown here and this is
taken from new england journal of
medicine
so genomics and bioinformatics have
contributed immensely to our
understanding of infectious diseases and
we can actually apply
sequencing data to study disease
pathogenesis or how
these pathogens cause disease we can
study
mechanisms of interaction between
proteins
of viral and bacterial pathogens and
host pathogens
or in the their hosts we can also
study the spread of antimicrobial
drug resistance and even the host immune
response in a very detailed way so
the result of these bioinformatics
tools and the sequencing methods is also
has led to the emergence of genomic
medicine that has substantially advanced
our ability to
detect study and treat infectious
diseases so one of the
major impacts of genomic medicine has
been on
infectious diseases over the years so as
a result
the ability to perform such
bioinformatics analysis
leverage some of these tools and access
these large data sets
is critical for all those of us that are
participating in such research
omix data is now regularly used to study
viral
genomes dna variation host gene
expression
protein abundance and composition
properties of microbial communities
and all of these are very different
types of data that all together
form a comprehensive holistic picture of
how these pathogens
interact with the host cause disease but
also
live in communities that we need to
learn how to study
and understand so what we'll do today is
we'll take a look at several examples
of how such data could be analyzed and
what type of information such data can
provide us with
so the role of bioinformatics in general
in the context of
infectious diseases will allow us to
study such data to extract uh important
information and so
what kind of information can we actually
extract
we can talk about the association of
viral genomics
and evolution placing that in the
context of
time and geolocation so we can ask
questions about where did a specific
pathogen originate
how does it spread in the population
what are some of the different
phenotypes that it produces in the
population
we can talk about immune response and
really
define how immune response is changing
in the course of disease progression and
ask questions about
what are those specific phenotypes
caused by which
genes and maybe identifying molecular
pathways that we can interfere with
leading us to novel drug design and
combinations of drugs that could be
effective at suppressing
disease manifestation as well as
addressing the specific
pathogen so how do we interfere with the
pathogen production colonization
and the production of toxins and also it
allows us to understand better
the conditions in which these pathogens
thrive and how to interfere so for
example
a large component of the immune response
is that initial microbiome composition
so we can ask questions about how does
that composition change
what are some of the factors that affect
the changes
and how we can be more informed about
the approaches to intervene
and to preserve a healthy component of
this
immune system or the immune response in
the microbiome
so one major way that bioinformatics is
actually changing our understanding of
the microbial world
is the ability to ask very basic
questions about individual organisms
their functionality
environment and the communities that
they form
and in fact this new sequencing
technology and the methods
have allowed us to not only look at
individual
pathogens but also study these
communities as a whole
and so a little bit of what we will
touch upon is the diversity
of viruses and bacteria as well as their
interaction with the microbiome and the
environment
that could be studied as a single
community
instead of just individual pathogens
that we
identify so what is the viral the virum
is one part of the microbiome
which constitutes all of the organisms
that inhabit us
including bacterial and archaeal
organisms as well as the microbiome and
other members of the male fauna
such as protists and metazones studies
of the viral
are actually in their infancy because it
has only recently become
possible to see and study the virum in
large sequence datasets using
bioinformatic tools that can detect
relationships between viruses
despite their extreme nucleotide
sequence diversity
and dynamics because they evolve and
rapidly change
the size of the mammalian virum is
actually not known
or and we think that there is a
tremendous diversity
and it still has to be studied further
to really understand how diverse it is
and it is continually updated through
rapid evolution of viruses and to
exposure to viruses in the environment
or in other mammals
so it's a fairly complex picture to or a
puzzle that has to be assembled together
before we can ask specific questions but
what
already is clear from the ability to
analyze sequences
are some questions about the very basics
or even
life itself so biologists have
categorized life
into three large domains bacteria
archaea
and eukarya and uh
we know that viruses were originally not
even considered
in this tree of life but these novel
abilities to compare
sequences and identify genes that are
responsible for specific type of
functionality
have really opened our research to
understand
viruses as potentially participants
in the dynamics and the diversity of
life itself
and we can think of them as agents of
change
because they have to be able to
replicate themselves using the cell
their host cell machinery
and as a result there's a lot of
exchange of genetic material that
happens between viruses
and their hosts that include bacteria
as well as eukarya and archaea and so
as a result we see this exchange of
genetic material
between these different hosts and we
now can think of viruses also as maybe
potentially a a uh part of this tree of
life in general
so before we continue and we'll talk
specifically about some of
the tools and methods that could be used
to analyze such data
let me pause here for a second and ask
first of all if you have any questions
before we continue but also let me ask
you
a couple of questions as well so i know
that there's a lot of people here some
of them are online
on youtube and some of you are online on
zoom
so if you're on zoom i would like to ask
if you could put down in the chat box
uh where are you from and what
institution are you uh
in working in studying in so
um really where are you located
geographically and what institution are
you in
uh so if you could use the chat box uh
and just uh let us know
um that would be great just so that we
have some sense of
where you are right now all right thank
you dr
dumas i see that you're from ethiopia
and please don't forget to mention what
institution you're a part of
sciences and technology university
and i see southeastern louisiana
university
thank you to caitlin sheffield
university
the neuroscience department thank you
kenya uh ke mri
i thank you miss shaq nairobi kenya
great
all right well um applied biology
department thank you
osmania university india kenya medical
research institute
african university of abu may khalabi
benin all right excellent so thank you
for sharing this information this is
going to be useful for us
as we plan these workshops for the
future
uh so again for anyone that is joining
us
uh we welcome you from all these
locations and it's great to have you
with us
today um so what will um okay thank you
and
we have somebody also here from lagos
nigeria uh so
um it would be great to continue and
stay in touch
and to really benefit from
some of these future webinars and some
of the resources that we provide
what we ask you to do if you would like
to
continue and participate in some of
these in the future is join
our social media groups so that we can
stay in touch so we have a group on
linkedin where we discuss
a lot of the emerging topics but also
have posts about different research
opportunities as well as career
opportunities so
if you are interested in bioinformatics
and comics data
please join our community on linkedin as
well as
on facebook and we
we can continue and share some of these
updates there
okay so let's go on uh we'll um
talk next about next generation
sequencing and really
how can next generation sequencing data
help us ask some of these questions in
relation to infectious diseases so one
of the major challenges
in omics data is of course the ability
to process the data
and extract meaningful information that
we can use to ask
very specific questions using analytical
tools
so this challenge is to process
visualize and organize data
so that these questions could be
answered
uh in metagenomic and viral sequencing
there are three types of sequencing
approaches that we're going to be
talking about today
there's what's called targeted
sequencing where we can amplify
a particular pathogen or a type
of microorganisms a specific taxonomic
classification so we can talk about
different types of primers that allow us
to sequence
a very specific type of a genome
we can also talk about amplicon
sequencing and amplicon sequencing means
that we amplify a particular region and
this could mean that we
combine specific library preparation
techniques as well as pcr
amplification to have enough material to
study
diversity for example and then of course
we can
sequence everything and sequencing
everything can
yield all dna so all of the
genomic material or all rna material and
so when we talk about
gene expression data the response of the
host
to infection we can study that using rna
sequencing so
we'll talk about some of these different
methods importantly
a lot of this type of data is actually
organized and made available to the
general
public so here you can see an example of
a couple of different places where you
can find stitch data
the joint genome institute as well as
the ncbi
provides us a very good view of how much
data has
been available and there is a lot of
rapid growth and accelerated
increase in the number of available
sequences now many of these data sets
are structured in other words they are
already assembled genomes
and these assembled genomes could be
viewed by a particular
name so you can go on this new project
for example called
ncbi virus and you can actually find
specific assembled
genomes or specific sections genes and
proteins
of those genomes and there's a lot of
what's called bio projects or sra
data sets that you can actually study
for novel types of tools that allow you
to compare different
components and sequences and gene
expression data and so
it really provides us with access to a
very diverse
set of data sets that we can use to ask
specific types of questions
now the data that we have access to
can also provide us with rapid
identification
of novel sequences so you can see how
such
viral outbreaks measures can be studied
using next generation sequencing
for example we can take data
specifically from
clinical specifics specimens and
identify either a particular viral
sequence and then
study that sequence and how it's
different from other sequences that we
already know about
or we can actually look at metagenomic
sequencing
and analyze all of the data that is
available there
potentially looking at multiple types of
viruses that are available
multiple types of pathogens that are
available and then study variation and
composition
of these communities within each sample
here you can also see some of the
additional ways that we can apply next
generation sequencing data analysis
tools
to identify detect resistance to
antimicrobial
antibiotic resistance analyze
changes in the microbiome community and
of course study the host gene expression
or
transcriptomic data now i mentioned
already that
the ability to analyze edge data
is complicated by the because this data
is
unstructured so essentially it consists
of
short reads you can see here millions
and
billions in fact of reads that could be
extracted from a single sample
and one of the challenges to make sense
of what does this
make data actually mean and to
do that we can assemble
these short reads and analyze those
reads linking them
to functional components so another
important
repository here is the repository of
reference sequences
sequences of either specific organisms
that we already
have studied and understand their
functionality as
for example in here you can see that one
of the first steps that had to happen
when this outbreak of this novel
coronavirus happened
is that we had to have a good reference
of this genome
so that we can map the reeds onto the
particular
genes in the genome and understand their
function
to study how does this virus actually
function
inside the host so once we have that
sequence and we can
map the reads that come from novel
sequencing samples onto this reference
genome
we can in fact start asking questions so
what kinds of
questions can we ask one question that
we ask
is sequence variation by aligning new
sequences that we have
to a reference and we can ask this about
the virus we can ask this about the
bacteria we can ask about any genome
that we have
by just mapping them onto a reference or
by mapping them together to identify
similarities
between different components that we
have identified
now to ask a question about
how they are related we can also conduct
evolutionary
analysis by looking at relationships
between these sequences and
organizing them into a phylogeny or how
they are
interrelated by coming from
some common origin we can also then ask
questions about
how the differences between these
genomes or genomic elements like genes
are functionally leading to changes so
here you can see
a mapping of mutations on one of the
proteins produced by a virus and the
question that we can ask
well how does that actually affect the
interaction between this protein
and a corresponding host protein
that could mean a change in the way the
disease
happens or the way that the transmission
happens
and then we can also ask questions about
the host response and really
that is a different approach here we are
more looking at the expression at the
levels of genes
how the the host response the
expression of genes varies between
different types of infections and at
different stages of infection
causing us to understand how the immune
response varies between different cells
of course in different tissues
okay so one of the things that i would
like to introduce now is
some of these approaches on the t-biome
for platform
where we have developed easy-to-use
tools that you can try and use
for analysis of phylogenetic
relationships
by identifying and mapping relationships
between genomic
elements that are different between each
other
how you can study a gene expression by
analyzing transcriptomic data
alignment of sequences to each other to
detect
prominent mutations and variations that
we can link to their function
functional changes how such data could
be
taken to the structure to understand the
relationship between sequence
and structure and how variant calling
and identification of particular markers
of
these genomic changes could help us
understand why
such structural changes are happening
so let's first talk about the alignment
uh the process of alignment
so multiple sequence alignment is a
typical approach to identify changes
based on nucleotide variation as well as
based on amino acid variation
so to analyze such data we need to
understand the differences in multiple
genomes and to compare those genomes
based on areas that are matching in
those sequences
and importantly to understand the
functional implications of such changes
we also need to understand the
relationship between
nucleotide sequence and amino acid
sequence so let me
give you an example i'm going to go to
the server platform so this is
the link and perhaps some of you that
are not joining us for the first time
might already be aware with this
platform
the platform was designed to incorporate
all of these different methods of
analysis
into a single interface and make it easy
to use for
even someone that is not
that does not have a technical
background in an engineering computer
science background
so one of the ways that you can uh try
out some of these methods before you
actually uh you know use this platform
for research
is by requesting a free demo account and
the way you can do that is you can
go into this access tab right here and
fill out this form
and you will actually get a free demo
account that you can try out some of the
things
that we are going to be doing now so i'm
going to show you a brief example
of what this multiple sequence alignment
really looks like
so that we can then try and apply it to
an example data set
so here i'm going to go to this virus
quasi species section
i'm going to go into this first demo
for multiple sequence alignment
this whole area is actually designed for
multiple use cases you can see that you
can identify
point mutations in sra files or fast q
files where we are expecting to find a
whole diverse population of let's say
viruses
you can also identify function of
defective viral genomes that might have
large
long sequences deleted from the full
genome
and you can also study relationships
between the sequences that have been
assembled
into haplotypes or if you have consensus
genomes
you can also understand the diversity of
these consensus genomes
so a very basic pipeline that could be
made here is
based on this data set of multiple types
of coronaviruses
which include the novel source cov2
genome
the bat genome of a similar virus
and then also sars one genomes and so
the question might be
how are they different and what do those
differences mean
in terms of their amino acid
substitutions
so here i'm going to just click on ok
and you can see that i have a section
here for multiple sequence alignments
i can press on multiple sequence
alignment that allows me
to understand specific similar
and different sections on the genome
converting those nucleotide sequences
into amino acid sequences which will
give us
insight into how different physical and
chemical properties of those regions are
changed
and i can then ask question well how
likely
is it for such a change to occur and
also what kind of
implications for this substitution will
i expect to find
on the functional level so i'm going to
click ok importantly we know that
the evolution or the accumulation of
mutations
does not happen in the same at the same
rate
in different types of codons and so i
can also
include different variation to how i
look at the specific codon positions to
analyze
this data and then i want to build
a phylogenetic tree that essentially
uses multiple sequence alignment
to determine relationships between
sequences
and assign time based on different
models
and you can see here a number of
different models that i could use
or i could just combine all of these
phylogeny methods together
and essentially what i will get as a
result is the
relationship between ancestors and the
present-day species
based on some assumption about how that
rate of mutation can lead to the changes
that i observe
in the samples that i have in my data
those
trees could be analyzed and i can
combine
all of the trees that i get as a result
because each different method will
produce a different result
and then select some of the most
representative trees
that i think are more linked to the
actual data that i have
based on comparison between multiple
trees
so clicking on end here will give us the
results
i can open this folder and take a look
at some of these results and
really start asking questions about what
does this
mean so let's first of all take a look
at some of these
results i have here
a ape tree which is one of the methods
and then here i have the beast
birth death process tree so we can take
a look at
what do they look like and how can this
give us insight into what these
different
types of sequences uh what type of
information do they contain and how are
they
organized into this relationship so here
you can see
that this phylogenetic tree a rooted
phytogenetic tree
contains one two three and four
defined groups and one of the questions
that i might
ask is how does the data that i
have about these sequences can help me
understand
what soros cove 2 for example what is
the closest relative for source code 2
out of all of the sequences that i have
uploaded
into this analysis so beyond just having
the ability to look at a phylogenetic
tree or look at the sequence variation
or maybe ask the question what is its
relationship
and how does this affect the amino acid
and the protein structure
ultimately i would like to link all of
this information together
so to do this we have actually created
a visualization tool to help
ask those specific questions so the same
tree that you are seeing right here the
same sequences that we see
there here they are in a more visual
and interactive format you can see
in this tool which we call sequence
navigator or cnav
you can see the sequences of the genomes
and those sequences are organized by
groups
here you can see mers sars
coveted 19 or source code 2 and beta
corona viruses
or other coronaviruses that are not
sars or mers and the
cells are bins each bin represents
500 nucleotides we can make it also into
250
so let's take a look at 500 first
well okay so they're loaded uh so here
we can see that each one of these bins
represents
a bin of 250 nucleotides
we have the reference genome that it is
mapped to and the difference
is color coded from gray all the way to
this darker red
so right away what we can see here are
some of the groups
are different in terms of how similar
they are to the reference genome
so based on what you see and you can by
the way
navigate to this link yourself and try
it out for yourself
which which group do you think
is the most dissimilar
to this reference genome
[Music]
okay you can type your answers into the
chat box which see which group of
sequences
is the least similar to the reference
genome
again gray is the most similar
red is the most dissimilar the most
distant
based on the number of changes that are
observed in that bin
each bin is about 250 nucleotides so
which group you can see that there are
groups
mers sars covid 19 or source code 2
and beta corona viruses so which group
do you think is the least
similar to this reference genome
okay so caitlyn is saying beta corona
viruses and
the shock is saying coven so uh
kate okay is also saying beta
coronaviruses
so let let's see what might be
some indications for this um
as i mentioned gray
is similar right so if i look at this
whole group
it is very similar because in fact they
don't have any variation here between
gray yellow and red
and so as a result i know that this
whole group which is covid
is the most similar to the reference
genome and the reason for this is of
course because
the reference genome is source code
2 and so it is exactly the same
reference genome
now if i want to look at other types of
comparisons i can for example take a
look at the covet 19 human genomic
sequences
and ask the questions how do these sars
code two genomes differ
between themselves but in the context of
these comparisons
this group stars cove two is the most
similar to the reference genome
so the question is which type of a virus
or group of
groups of viruses are different from the
source code
ii and the answer is that indeed like
you mentioned
either this group which is mers or
this group like beta coronaviruses so
beta corona viruses contain a lot of red
in specific regions right including this
region right here
and this region right here so let's now
talk about
what might this mean so i have here
sars which is source code 2 which is
very similar to sars
one and quite dissimilar with
mers and beta corona viruses
so one question i can ask well how are
they
related to each other in other words
which one is closer
and which one is farther away and so the
answer to that is this phylogenetic tree
the phylogenetic tree tells me
which groups are closely related to each
other and which ones are farther away
from each other so here you can see
that covid19 and sars1
are closely related and they are closer
related
to mers than they are to the beta corona
viruses
so even though just looking at the
sequence alignment
i don't really know which ones they are
closer to because there's so much
variation if i look at the phylogenetic
tree
which gives a model for how
one type of a sequence could originate
from another one
i can start organizing these into
relationships
and these relationships tell me that in
fact they do
differ in in terms of how closely
related they
are to each other now the other thing
that i can ask
is how do the groups within
each defined group or each clade
relate to each other as well and i can
see that they all
do have differences as well and these
differences
are actually related to time and so i
can see that
beta corona viruses have the greatest
diversity in terms of time just because
they see that
this axis which corresponds to
evolutionary time
shows me a greater divergence between
the actual sequences
and also in this group right here which
is coveted 19
that diversity almost does not exist
which is very logical of course
because code 19 has been around just for
such a brief time and this time
incorporates such viruses that have been
around for years and years
and so the diversity of the samples that
i have in the different groups
actually represents very different
physical time or real time
and therefore this evolutionary time
differs between diversity measurements
in each one of these groups
the other question that i might ask
is how the differences that i observe
at specific positions on the genomes
could be interpreted by looking at what
proteins
they encode for so here i have
this reference genome that also shows
the different proteins and these
proteins could be
or these genes and here i can
look at these genes and what actually
they do so you can see that
one of these additional areas that have
a lot of dissimilarity
is the surface like a protein or the
spike
as glycoprotein so here i have
this spike glycoprotein we know that it
is responsible for
interaction with the host protein
for cell entry i can actually see this
3d structure of this protein
and read about what it is and i actually
actually
go to this link which will take me to
the ncbi
where i can find more information about
this protein
and that full sequence so this is an
important component as well
not only am i asking the question how do
these different sequences related
what areas are mostly related
or most dissimilar but also i can ask
the question
of what might be the functional result
from
changes in that protein and so as you go
deeper into these comparisons more and
more questions could be
answered by studying these sequences
inside each sequence remember that
there's
250
250 nucleotides and here if you hover
over
you can see how many of those are
actually different
from the reference so you can see that
this very red one
has 220 changes from the reference
this one has 57 and of course a gray one
can have zero or a very small number
like
three so this tool allows us to
interpret some of the results from such
sequence
analysis from such multiple sequence
alignment and phylogeny to
start understanding what might be some
differences
in terms of where these genomes
originated from
and how these genomes could be different
in the way that they interact with the
host and here since we see so many
changes in the specific
spike glycoprotein we can start asking
additional questions
about what specific changes are there
and how can they explain the differences
between
what this virus does and how does it
actually cause
disease so this is
an important kind of a tool in the
toolkit that we have to compare
assembled sequences by aligning them to
each other
and understanding what types of
mutations or changes
we can observe in the sequences that we
have in our data
now importantly not all of the
changes are represented equally in the
data that we have
if we have full fast queue files and
these fast q
files actually represent specific
sequences from reads short reads
we can see that some of the changes in
those reads could be of high confidence
for example if i have a read that i can
detect in
multiple reads and all of them agree
they give me the same result and i know
that it is a change from the reference
i will be confident in that change but
in some cases i have a lot of variation
so even though i see a change that
change is very different inside
different reads
if it is different inside different
reads i really cannot call this
a variant and so the variation between
the different reads
in the sequences of the reference genome
have different weights
and different types of information that
they can give me
to understand how those mutations
are accumulating in the population of
viruses that i'm studying
now for this purpose it is important to
call variance and distinguish between
the different types of variation that i
have in the data
so here we have an example you can see
that this is coverage
and identification of these specific
types of positions where i have high
confidence
is also carried along with positions
that i have low confidence
and sometimes the proportion between
them changes as
well so this is an additional piece of
information because
the reality is this typically represents
a diverse population of sequences
that accumulate as the virus replicates
inside the cell
so if i'm looking at this situation i
have a particular
original virus coming into the cell or
coming
into the host it replicates and
has to evade multiple pressures
associated with
the immune response and competition
between different
progenies of this individual virus and
as a result
a lot of mutations occur and i can
actually study the variation
of this population using some of these
mutations that accumulate in the
individual genomes
that i can sample so if i take a sample
one single sample let's say from a
patient and take another sample from a
different patient
i can actually ask the question not only
how the
genome in each one of those of a
specific pathogen
is different but i can also see what
diversity levels am i observing
and oftentimes these diversity levels
are associated
with virulence and the uh
the danger that they can carry for the
immune system
because as the virus mutates it is the
only strategy essentially that it has to
evade the detection
and suppression of what it does inside
the cell
and so as it accumulates these mutations
some of those mutations can become more
significant
in other words the virus of with that
particular mutation becomes more
abundant and in some cases some other
mutations
can become less significant so they can
really represent
some kind of a dying out population now
again to piece all of that information
together
i can also organize the relationship
between these different types of viruses
into one single tree and then i can
study these trees
to understand populations and this type
of an analysis
phylogenetic analysis can be very
powerful for me to
start associating with whatever i
observe
at the phenotypic level so a good
example of that
is of course this visualization
that probably most of us are already
familiar with
that allows us to link how time
diversity in the viral population
and some phenotypic information about
the location
or maybe the number of people that were
infected in a particular region
could all be linked together now
importantly
we see that these mutations do not
accumulate equally
in each viral genome or
in each viral gene sorry
so the prominent mutations the mutations
that start
emerging in a particular region on a
particular time frame
are important for us to study further
now what kind of
information can we extract from
a carefully selected number of sequences
when we start looking at the in-depth
meaning
of these mutations let's take an example
the example that we'll look at is the
example
of this specific comparison
between changes in covid19
genome as compared to some of the sars1
genomes and the bat
coronavirus genome to try to ask the
question
of what might be the probable origin
and how might the virus originate
from a similar species like a bat
or a pangolin as compared to the
coronavirus that we observe in the human
and so to do that first of all an
important part of such a question
is finding the right data and typically
the way that we can select for the right
type of data to ask such
questions is to first analyze large
quantities of data
to study variation overall and then to
reduce the number of genomes
to a very particular set of genomes that
we have high
confidence in so these could be
consensus genomes
and based on that consensus genome we
can start
asking very specific questions about
individual positions on the genome
that show some major change that we
think have a functional
implication so for example if we start
from
an analysis overall here you can see how
analysis between many genomes
could be converted into a comparison of
overall similarity across the genomic
positions
and identify very specific regions
that show high difference
now that high difference could now be
interpreted
by asking very specific questions about
the positions that are different and the
distance between the positions
what do i mean so here we have an
overall kind of an overview of how we
can take the study further for example
if i know of a particular protein just
like we saw the spike glycoprotein
has a lot of variation
within that sequence of that protein
let's say the spike glycoprotein is
about 1500
nucleotides long sorry
1500 amino acids long so we can
start asking the questions of how can we
identify the functional significance of
those
changes so here we see amino acid
sequences
that we can analyze in terms of sequence
identity how are they uh similar
how which context are they placed in
and also what types of features can we
identify
in those genomic sequences we can also
look at the 3d structure
and think about how can we position the
changes that we observe
in the sequence on this folded structure
so which ones are outside which ones are
inside which ones are interacting
together which ones are
more distant from each other and
obviously we can also
generate high throughput data that shows
us the response of the host
that could be different because specific
positions have changed
so here is an analysis of such data
for this spike like a protein and you
can see that
this is the percentage similarity
on the reference genome sorry
and you can see that the major changes
occur
in the spike protein so these major
changes across groups of
different sequences reveal the
changes that we can start looking into
deeper and we can separate the spy
glycoprotein
into different functional domains and
these functional domains
are corresponding to the different types
of activity that this protein
actually assists with
so if we look at this receptor binding
domain the specific position
of mutations that we can see they
accumulate significantly in the receptor
binding domain
and we can link that to our
understanding of the overall
interaction between the viral proteins
and the host
proteins for example we know
that it interfaces with the human
protein that sits on the membrane right
it is a protein
that is responsible for cell entry
and so we can see how the specific uh
protein of the virus the spike
glycoprotein interacts with the h2
which is hosted inside this protein
called
b081 so the interaction between the
virus
and the human
cell is first interfacing in the
receptor binding domain
and just one part of this ace ii
b081 complex
now as we look into this receptor
binding domain
we can see that it is only about
200 nucleotides long and this 200
nucleotide
sequence could be studied in much
greater detail
to reveal how the particular
changes that we observe in the genome
are responsible for
adaptation because we know
that the complex that we observe here
and the specific receptor that is
two in humans is also different between
different species
so by analyzing the genomic sequences
of the pathogen and analyzing the
genomic sequences of the host
we can start answering the question
of how a particular interaction
between different hosts can help us
trace the evolution of the virus
as it came from other species and
eventually started infecting the humans
now answering that question conclusively
can also help us identify the specific
positions
in the interaction between these two
proteins that could be
intervened in or that could be trained
for the human immune system to be able
to recognize the specific binding
positions and the specific variation
that is typical
in these types of infections that we can
start designing
vaccines and drugs
now let's take a look at another example
here's an example
of ebola virus and the ebola virus
is also very diverse and has
occurred in several different pandemics
that were observed
in the west africa region now in that
west africa region
we can take samples and by the way this
was one of the
the 2014-2016
[Music]
outbreaks was one of the first major
efforts in near real time
sequencing that produced thousands and
thousands of
samples that we can analyze for
diversity now looking at that diversity
we can identify the most prominent
changes
in the viral sequences that were sampled
and identify which proteins
are they accumulated in so for example
in this study you can see how again we
have
multiple reads from many many samples
from population samples those reads were
aligned together into the reference
genome
as a result of the alignment we identify
specific positions
and those positions can reveal important
proteins
where such mutations can play a
functional role
that could be linked to virulence
transmission
and ultimately inform vaccine design
importantly we have today an antiviral
drug
and a vaccine for the ebola virus as a
result of bioinformatics and as a result
of such analyses
so having access to data and access to
tools that could be used
can help us identify specific changes
and ask the question of their functional
significance
as well as what type of information
could they
reveal that is important for drug and
vaccine design
but so far we've talked a lot about
viruses
what about other types of pathogens
specifically
bacterial pathogens like tuberculosis
and
such pathogens like malaria which are
actually
also developing drug resistance
so for those types of bacterial
uh infections and these types of
situations one of the similar approaches
can actually help us reveal
what genomic variation is responsible
for single antibiotic resistant or
multiple
antibiotic resistant types of pathogens
so here you can see specific mutations
that are associated
with different types of drugs
where resistance in tuberculosis is
developed
now that is not done by looking at just
individual positions and multiple
sequence alignment if we return
to this platform interface we can see
that some
additional important sections are
available here
to ask such questions of genomic data
so for example here we have genome-wide
association studies
that essentially help us ask the
question
if i have a defined phenotype and that
phenotype
is resistance to a particular drug let's
say i know that a drug
is being administered in this region in
this hospital for this patient
how can i ask the question what is the
association
between the specific variation in the
genome of that pathogen
and what is the association with the
phenotype right so if the phenotype
sorry i'm trying to meet someone
um if the phenotype
okay there we go
so if i can find such an association
i can actually identify which mutation
is responsible for accumulation of drug
resistance
similarly i can have a more of
an approach of multi-omics integration
where i have an ability to ask the
question
how is a mutation specifically
responsible
for the interaction with the host so if
i have the host data
and i have the genomic data from
my viral or bacterial pathogen
i can start looking for associations in
such
data sets that can reveal interaction
between different proteins and signaling
pathways
and help me identify how to intervene
in those interactions
now importantly the examples that i'm
showing you are just
to get you thinking about what types of
analysis
what types of data and what types of
questions
you might have about a project that is
interesting to you
so these examples are based on some
publications that what we did is
we took the data from those publications
we looked at the methods that they used
and then we combined those together to
produce tutorials
that could be used as a starting point
for a research project now if you're a
student
or you're just learning about
bioinformatics what you might want to do
is you might want to do some similar
analysis
and develop a novel and independent
project
and such a novel and independent project
can really give you a sense of how such
tools can be used
for this type of data now as i mentioned
such data
is widely available one example that we
can briefly look at
is on ncbi virus
where a lot of this data is hosted and
is freely available
so i'm just going to go to ncbi virus
first and then i'll also
show a couple of examples from the ncbi
repository where you can look at data
sets
for other types of pathogens
so an ncbi virus you can start by
searching by sequence or
you can look by virus so if all of you
trying this tool out what you can easily
do here is
enter for example ebola virus
you can just wait a couple of seconds
you can see that the ebola virus appears
right here and i can
access over 3000 sequences
from ebola virus and you can see that
they come from different locations
they come from different sources at
different time frames
so i can really start designing my
questions
around the data sets that are available
right here
let's go back and instead of ebola virus
let's look for coronavirus
so here you can see the whole corona
verde and the corona viridae
also comes from different hosts so
animal hosts as well as human hosts
and i can also narrow this
for different locations geographic
region
isolation source and dates so again
the same type of analysis that we went
through today comparing different
sequences
and asking what might those sequence
analysis
results mean functionally you can also
conduct
just by taking data from here another
great repository
is for all other types of data where you
can also find
host response to coronavirus infection
you can find
malaria sequences tuberculosis sequences
ebola virus and other pathogenic
sequences
as well as the host response and you can
really start looking at
both the diversity of these viral
populations the
microbiome that they that they
best develop in or worse develop in and
also the response to different
treatments so here if you look for
[Music]
coronavirus
you will see that there's of course
a lot of different types of data that
you can find
including gene expression data
over 3000 gene expression omnibus data
sets
you can see 351 bio projects
which in in each in all of these
projects together have over
100 000 bio samples so you really have
a lot of access to data sets right here
and
over a hundred thousand sra which is the
sequence read archive or the raw fast q
file so really
a tremendous diversity of data sets uh
if you just look through some of the
titles of these bio projects
you can find what type of data sets are
available
and think how can you ask a specific
question of these data sets for example
evaluating the microbial context of
source code two inpatients and the
hospital-built environment
or uh super spreading events preceding a
large meat processing plant-related
source coronavirus two-hour break in
germany
right so really fascinating data sets
many of these data sets
have a publication associated with it
and some of them don't because they're
very new
so you can see that this was submitted
on the 3rd of november so just recently
there's not even a publication
associated with this data set
and you can easily access over 1000
samples here
to start asking questions well what is
really going on
and how can i ask this question based on
the data that i have available
so i think that this represents a huge
opportunity
to design and develop novel types of
projects
that you can start using some of the
tools and the data sets that we have
discussed today
now i also want to tell you a little bit
about
the training that our company provides
to help you get started
using some of the tools and the methods
that we discussed
we run a series of onyx logic training
programs
that are intended to provide
bioinformatics guidance
for independent research using
bioinformatics
with assistance from mentors and peer
example
and our goal is to develop a community
that has data-driven research interest
and an appreciation of citizen science
and
we want to make sure that students
clinicians faculty of all backgrounds
are able to apply bioinformatics
effectively
to these kinds of questions and so
thinking about the
interest and the available resources for
infectious diseases we've designed
this novel program called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases
this program will help you understand
pathogens
and the diseases that they cause by
analyzing data
and learn about the different analysis
approaches that can help
detect viral genomes in next generation
sequencing data
to ask questions about how these
sequences are different
and apply those types of analyses to
different types of
functional and important projects like
vaccine design
antiviral drug design antibiotic
resistance
epidemiology and others
what we provide in the context of this
project of this program
are curated projects and data sets just
like what we discussed today very
briefly
in this program we will go through in
much greater detail
and so we'll talk about uh different
types of viruses like coronaviruses and
also
different types of bacterial pathogens
as well
the programs are really uh combined out
of several different elements
they include online sessions like today
we try to make them interactive and
they're conducted by multiple
uh guides that we have in our program
they also have access to self-guided
study materials that you can access
independently and some practical
assignments
so let me briefly show you what those
look like
so the platform that we already talked
about
is one of these resources this resource
allows you to
analyze publicly available data sets
easily with a user
interface we also have a number of
projects
that you can use to get started with
your research project or analyze data
from
other types of data sets and we have
coding exercises and i'll just briefly
show you one of these coding exercises
that is
very basic but introduces you into
coding practices using r and python
to analyze genomic sequences so here you
can see
a breakdown of the code you can then
learn about
more advanced variation of the analysis
including pairwise analysis and multiple
sequence alignment
and importantly you get these
assignments where you have to modify the
code
and run it to produce a result now all
of this
interaction with the coding assignments
with
uh running individual pipelines or even
completing some of the lessons and
projects that you will see right here
all of this becomes available under your
individual profile and so you get to
build up a profile
of your own to demonstrate what types of
skills
you have achieved by participating in
the program
and also develop an independent project
and we have a number of examples
that you can also look on our website to
see what students have been able to
develop as a result
of participating in a project like this
in a program like this
so to summarize the program will start
on november 9th it is called
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
and
it is a training program a
bioinformatics training program
that will help you explore relevant
tools methods and data repositories
learn from curated case studies and
peer-reviewed publications
test your understanding by analyzing
sample data
master key elements of analysis and
visualization
as well as design and develop an
independent research project
so these are some of the key topics that
we will cover
in this program and this program will
start
on november 9th now importantly
we have a place where you can find all
of these
details called bioinformatics
for infectious diseases and i'm just
going to paste
the link in the chat as well
on here you will find the details
including a brief overview of the
program
the schedule of the program so we will
have these different
sessions together in each one you will
find a description of what topic will be
covered
what is included in the program
registration
some of the comments some of the access
to some of the
resources that you will have some of the
projects
and some of the tools that we mentioned
and of course the sessions
are just one example of the types of
projects
are the programs that we run so you're
welcome to explore some of the
additional programs that we have
available here as well
okay so thank you again for joining to
today
for this brief presentation i am happy
to answer any questions now that you
might have
about what we talked about today
including the program and including some
of the topics that we discussed in the
project examples that we discussed
so if you have any question you're
welcome to
write it in the chat and i will answer
those
you